Hello World Saroj here.
The interplanetary file system.
More IPFS is a new protocol that could upgrade the entire Internet.
A protocol is just a set of rules written with software and the Internet is made
up of a bunch of them.
They want handled different things.
Email,
data,
transfer page layout,
a bunch of stuff.
The http protocol,
because the most popular one you don't go.
When you go to a website it says http and at the beginning of the URL bar,
that's because your web browser is using the http protocol to retrieve the page.
Each GDP was created by a stream of gene and Tim Burns Lee in 1989 it defines to
an a client and a server and it enables each to request data from the other back
and forth if their request was successful or response to send back.
So when you type in http colon slash slash [inaudible] dot com in your browser,
which is the client,
it uses HDP to request as well main page and Google server using http to send it
to you as a response.
That's it.
That simple protocol is the backbone of the entire worldwide web.
It connects all of our computing devices together,
phones,
tablets,
laptops,
everything.
But ADP isn't good enough anymore.
In fact,
it's kind of totally broken.
AGB has made the web become totally centralized.
That means I'd handful of apps on all of our data.
It profit off of our data that we freely give to them to return for a free
service.
Well,
this may seem cool at first.
This is actually shrinking the economy.
We're living in a data economy.
Data is the asset of this new world.
In a good economy,
we should be monetizing more and more.
But in a centralized internet,
we're monetizing less and less.
These central servers are getting more and more powerful by absorbing all of our
data.
Servers are given a unique IP address,
which defines its location,
but that location is far away.
It takes longer to retrieve the data,
and because data is a location address,
if that location gets shutdown at data is lost forever.
All of it,
it's just not sustainable.
But maybe we could make a permanent web,
uh,
web where links never die.
That's the vision of IPFS.
It's a pure to pure protocol.
There's no central server people connect to each other directly.
That means if you built a website on IPFS,
it could never be shut down by anyone.
Even if the government shuts down Internet access during protests,
people could still communicate with each other offline with Ip effects.
That is a potential to say actual human models and data will be owned by us.
The people,
not by one group.
We could get paid for our data instead of one group profiting off of all of it
and because IPFS is peer to peer data transfer is much,
much faster.
The network give data,
a content address,
not an IP address,
so if you want to load a website,
you set up your computer requesting it from a server across the world,
it'll find the nearest copy.
Maybe that random dude sitting next to you in chemistry has it on his laptop and
your computer would retrieve it from there directly and if multiple people have
copies of it,
your computer would request it from all of them at the same time.
The more peers no faster than download videos with loads so much faster.
You can download games 10 times faster.
It's just better in every way.
IPFS who's going to help our computers talk to each other much more efficiently
and one day if we become an interplanetary species,
IPFS could be a protocol we use to communicate with each other.
If you're on Mars,
you don't want to have to stream that video from Earth.
If your friends sitting next to in the Martian don't Ardi has checkout IPFS best
dot ios to start learning more about it and ways that you can build
decentralized apps.
There are a couple of great demos to get started right on the website.
If you'd like to see more technology videos,
please subscribe.
I really appreciate it and as always,
thanks for watching.